[Music]
i was delighted to serve as co-chair of
the president's committee on diversity
inclusion and belonging the work is very
important
for our society and for our university
but it's not easy
i was tremendously impressed by the
expertise generosity
and thoughtful contribution of each
member of the committee
each one of them brought a different
kind of expertise to the table
their knowledge and experience their
commitment to deep discussions
and their collective wisdoms allowed us
to continue our work during a very
challenging spring and summer
and to produce a report for president
salovey that i think we can all be proud
of
the report builds on previous university
initiatives
and proposes a forward-looking framework
i am confident
that the group's recommendations will
serve here well for many years to come
i'm ann curth the dean of the yale
school of nursing
it's a good moment to have this report
coming out the coven 19 crisis
has really demonstrated the racial
disparities in health care
that black indigenous people of color
and other populations have suffered from
in our country for many years
this is a timely moment it's a pivotal
one
the nation is calling for justice and
yale can respond
higher education needs to be a part of
this movement
at the school of nursing we are making
diversity equity inclusion belonging
and anti-racism work a priority because
we must reflect the communities we serve
in the way that we educate practice
and conduct research much learning has
to happen and i'm learning also
white people must listen with intention
to our bipod colleagues friends
students and loved ones we've spent 400
years centering white voices
now we must center in the voices stories
and narratives of our bipark
members and support
their needs to thrive
nothing less would be right
as an institution and as a larger
community
yale as always can lead by example and
take bold action
this report is a step in that direction
my name is darren lattimore i am deputy
dean
of diversity equity inclusion at the
school of medicine
i first want to say it was an honor to
be on the president's committee
each of us looks at these issues through
our own lenses
however it was immediately clear
that all of us felt a strong commitment
to creating a just environment
at yale university i also want to thank
our community
many of us interviewed students staff
and faculty in order to
get the information that we needed to
create the most robust plan
possible
i'm very grateful that i was on the
committee because at the same time
i was actually developing a strategic
plan
for the school of medicine it was really
helpful
to be able to see what the university is
doing in the dei
space as i created my plan because i
want to make sure that the strategies
that i use at the medical school
are in line with the strategies that the
university as a whole are using
and the outcomes that i'm measuring are
the same ones that the university as a
whole
are measuring i like to say
when we're all going in the same
direction working together
there's a much better chance that we'll
get the outcome that we want
hello my name is weylie chang i am the
executive director of the yale alumni
association
the mission of the yale alumni
association states
our character strength and values come
from our diversity and our commitment to
a culture of inclusion and equity
our mission is to enhance and renew the
lifelong yale experience
for all alumni whoever they are
and wherever they may be so who are
our alumni our alumni community is a
diverse group that spans
generations identities yale affiliations
and interests so a core value of the
yale alumni association
is inclusion what does inclusion mean
it means that we strive for full
engagement and a sense of belonging
among our alumni
all of our alumni have had the privilege
of experiences and
opportunities at and because
of yale these experiences and
opportunities
influence our choices and decisions and
in turn
these choices and decisions can
positively impact our communities
especially if there is an understanding
of diversity equity
inclusion and belonging
at this moment in time we have an
opportunity
and an obligation to advance these
important principles
they are priorities for the yale alumni
association
and for the university
i remember so clearly those meetings
after we received our charge from
president salovey
to shape the next phase of the
university's work on diversity equity
and inclusion
as well as belonging what a great
committee and we had some really
amazing conversations so many members of
the committee
have expertise in these areas or have
been citizens of the university for a
very long time
so they understand our culture we talked
often about how this
work is more of a marathon and not a
spread
we reviewed the work that has been done
by generations of students and faculty
staff and alumni
we talk to a lot of people on campus and
we compiled a pretty amazing list
of every project that's currently
underway or being planned
in the schools and in the administrative
units
i began to think of this whole project
differently
the committee's recommendations and the
president's priorities
not so much as a marathon but as a part
of a relay race
individuals complete marathons right
but teams actually compete in relay
races
and each person leg has an
individual contribution that's unique to
that person
so the committee's work is really about
passing the baton
the baton if you will toward a more
inclusive
a more diverse a more excellent yale
a yale where every member feels a sense
of belonging
and that baton has a common vision
a guiding principle and goals to align
the work
that's being done work that spans
schools and generations
identities and views that baton
also includes actions for the first five
years of this next phase
and all of this by the way can be found
online
yes we're moving into the next phase
of this race and we have the ability to
create
real change and together that is what we
will do
we all belong here we all belong to yale
so let's make sure that we show up for
ourselves and for each other
let's make sure that this part of the
journey counts